Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan. Wir stehen wieder vor dem Salon und du bist gerade zurück aus Hamburg.
Jo.
Wie war's?
Gut. Kleiner Reisereport, bevor ich sage warum. Ich sitze in Rom und weiß,
morgen Abend in Hamburg geht's zur Sache.
Und dann kommt eine Push-Notifikation, Flughafen in München wird prophylaktisch gesperrt.
Ich erahne schon, was am nächsten Tag passiert, dass nämlich Jörg Kachelmann
sich darüber lustig macht, dass München die einzige Stadt ist,
die einen Weltraumbahnhof plant, aber dann wegen ein bisschen Eisregen den Flughafen
sperrt. So kam der Tweet dann auch.
Also, Landesredaktion angerufen, mein Flug ist weg. Okay, bin ich halt über Amsterdam geflogen.
Ich kam nach 8 Stunden Reise sehr pünktlich in Hamburg an. Und dann wurde mir
gesagt, ja, wir machen ja heute zwei Aufzeichnungen, wie Sie wissen.
Die erste Sendung ging noch nicht mal los.
Saskia Esken sitzt noch im Zug. Also es war mal wieder, in Deutschland hat es geschneit.
Und die Züge aus Berlin nach Hamburg sind tatsächlich rückwärts gefahren, teilweise.
Um nochmal eine Weiche vorher, dann doch nochmal einen Schlenker irgendwo rumzufahren.
Allen tat alles sehr leid. Ich saß dann auch da und mir tat sehr leid zu wissen,
dass irgendwelche Leute, die ja dann noch performen müssen, vorher so ein Stressentzug,
wo sie nicht mal wissen, kommen wir überhaupt an oder so. Bei mir war es einfach
eine geplante lange Reise.
Also sehr aufregende Zeit.
Das heißt, wir können dich bald bei Lanz erleben.
Ja, man kann mich bei Lanz erleben mit Gästen, die glaube ich viele freuen werden,
die Pointen können wir uns ja auch nicht verraten.
Ich dürfte es bestimmt, aber ich würde es jetzt gar nicht so sagen.
Die Pointen purzeln dann Schritt für Schritt.
Und ich weiß, es ist die letzte Sendung des Jahres. Es könnte sein.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wo man jetzt nachguckt, auf cdf.de oder so,
oder in der Höhe zu, weil die letzte Landsendung taktiert ist.
Aber es ist die letzte Landsendung des Jahres. Könnte durchaus sein,
dass das mit unserem K-Salon sich überschneidet.
Dass ich also an dem Abend auf der Bühne denselben Anzug anhabe mit anderem
Hemd wie dann abends im Fernsehen, denn ich wollte natürlich den ersten grünen anziehen.
Sehr gut. Wir müssen noch mal ganz kurz über ein Thema sprechen,
das wir schon aufgegriffen hatten im letzten Podcast, nämlich es soll noch mal
um diese KfW-Kredite für Studenten geben.
Du hast mich gerade darauf hingewiesen, es gibt einen Tweet von Maurice Höfken
dazu, denn es war ja bislang immer die Aussage,
ja die KfW verdient ja mit der Kreditvergabe gar kein Geld, die gibt ja einfach
nur die Zinsen, die nötig sind, dann an ihre Kunden weiter und jetzt schreibt
aber Maurice gerade was?
Ich lese, die KfW macht in den ersten neun Monaten des Jahres 1,2 Milliarden
Euro Gewinn, aber könne sich nicht leisten, die neun Prozent Mondzinsen für
Studentenkredite zu reduzieren.
Sehr interessant.
Ja, das finde ich vor allem interessant, bevor wir den Eklips hören.
Die KfW ist ja die Kreditanstalt für Wiederaufbau.
Also das ist ja so ein ganz typisches Konstrukt, wie beim Solidaritätszuschlag.
Wird einmal eingerichtet und dann umgewidmet.
Und wir haben ja besprochen, solche Umwidmungen können sehr schnell nach hinten losgehen.
Im Rahmen der KfW ist es aber wirklich eine eigenständige Bank in Obhut des
Staates, also nicht nur so ein Fonds oder so, die darf das dann einfach über
ihre Zwecke selbst bestimmen. sich sozusagen der Managemententscheidung ausliefern.
Aber es ist dieselbe Frage wie bei der Bahn. Sie bietet einen Service an,
der fragwürdig ist, warum er Profit abwerfen soll, wenn es doch wirklich eine
Zielorientierung gibt im Sinne von, Nee, wir wollen ja, dass die Menschen irgendwo
ankommen, damit zum Beispiel eine Landsendung stattfinden kann und nicht,
ja, wir machen daraus auch noch ein Geschäft. So.
Also warum werden bei der Bahn Gewinne verbucht und sogar Boni ausgezahlt ans Management?
Und warum macht die KfW Gewinn? Also ich würde das eben auch unter dieser Vereinstätigkeit.
Wir wollen einfach, dass da interessenbezogen etwas stattfindet und nicht zielorientiert
auf Gewinn. Und unter dieser Maßgabe ist gerade heute diese Nachricht,
dass drei Quartale ausreichen um 1,2 Milliarden.
Also wir haben es mit 400 Millionen im Monat, mit mehr als 100 Millionen,
im Quartal mit mehr als 100 Millionen Profiten im Monat zu tun und damit sind
wir jetzt auf der Kategorie monatlich Zahlungspflichtigkeit.
Ja.
Oben 14hundert Millionen raus und jetzt erklärst du uns wie die unten reinkommen.
Die kommen rein durch die armen Studenten, die zum Beispiel einen Kredit abgeschlossen
haben, aber ohne Zinsbindung und einen solchen hat Nils Schniederjahn vom Deutschlandfunk getroffen.
Wir hören uns das aber jetzt nicht ganz an, die Problemlage bei diesem Studenten,
aber um erstmal das Problem zu verstehen, hören wir mal rein.
Im Gegensatz zum BAföG war der Kredit schnell bewilligt. Der Zinssatz damals
3,7 Prozent. Ich bin davon ausgegangen, dass die Konditionen,
zu denen ich diesen Kredit abschließe, quasi bestehen bleiben.
Das war aber nicht der Fall.
Denn Erik schloss seinen Kreditvertrag mit flexiblem Zinssatz ab.
Theoretisch bietet die KfW auch Studienkredite mit Zinsbindung an.
Aber nur ein Bruchteil der Studierenden nutzt diese Form.
Ein Bruchteil macht das nur. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt ganz viele Studenten,
die in die Situation kommen, dass sie plötzlich hohe Abträge leisten müssen,
auch um die Profite der KfW zu steigern.
Und wenn man sich mal diese Zahlen so vor Augen führt, die du jetzt schon genannt
hast, dann wird einem so alles klar, wenn wir uns das hier vergegenwärtigen.
Die durchschnittlichen Zinszahlungen sind deutlich gestiegen.
Vor zwei Jahren zahlte jeder ehemalige Student pro Monat im Durchschnitt rund 34 Euro an Zinsen.
Im vergangenen Monat waren es bereits 83 Euro.
Ja, also wir hatten, da wir es zuletzt auch ansprachen, einige Hörermeldungen zum Thema.
Hat Stefan noch nie einen Kredit abgeschlossen? Weiß der nicht,
was eine Zinsbindung ist und so?
Ja, ich habe schon meinen Kredit abgeschlossen, aber ich finde es trotzdem,
es widerspricht sozusagen meinem intuitiven Verständnis von,
wie soll man sagen, Vertragsaugenhöhe der Vertragspartner und so weiter,
dass man sagt, okay, wir einigen uns darauf, wir leihen dir so und so viel Geld,
diese Summe ist unveränderlich, du kannst ja einfach später kommen und sagen,
ich brauche da noch ein bisschen mehr oder ich möchte es gerne früher zurückzahlen,
das kostet dann alles extra, beziehungsweise mehr Geld gibt es dann einfach
nicht, weil man hat ja irgendwas ausgeschöpft.
Und die andere Seite sagt aber, ja, was das dann kostet, sagen wir dir im Verlauf,
weil am Ende, ich gehe auch nicht zur Rewe einkaufen oder Edeka,
ich nenne immer Rewe, aber ich meine Supermärkte.
Also ich gehe nicht in den Supermarkt und sage, ich hätte jetzt gern diesen Warenkorb.
Und dann kommt einfach das Unternehmen und sagt, ja, wir sagen Ihnen dann übermorgen, was das kostet.
Weil so geht man ja zur KfW. Klar, man kriegt dort einen Kredit und es ist Geld,
aber man geht dort, man füllt einen Warenkorb mit einer Sache,
die man braucht, Geld und irgendwie entscheiden die dann einfach, was das kostet.
Also das ist doch, ich meine ich finde es schon irre, dass man bei einer Tankstelle
erst hinfährt und sozusagen keine Planungshoheit hat, sondern man muss dann
erst vor Ort sehen auf dieser Tafel, was das kostet. Das ist schon bescheuert.
Aber einen Einkauf zu tätigen, nach Hause zu fahren.
Das Gemüse aufzuessen und dann irgendwann mal zu erfahren, was es kostet,
finde ich irgendwie blöd. Ja, also das ist einfach.
Und jetzt kann man sagen, das ist bei allen Krediten so, das stimmt,
aber hier würde ich auch festhalten wollen, es handelt sich um besondere Kredite,
nämlich eigentlich sind das ja Ermöglichungen für Leute, die nicht viel Geld
im Rücken haben, von der Familie haben,
um zu studieren, um dann etwas wahrscheinlich sehr wichtiges für die Gesellschaft zu tun.
Und denen könnte man ja andere Konditionen zukommen lassen, warum gibt es da
überhaupt etwas mit Zinsbindung und so weiter.
Man weiß ja, wenn man Kredite mit Zinsbindung abschließt, dann sind diese ja teurer.
Das ist ja logisch und das kann sich dann rechnen für einen.
Rechnen oder rechnen?
Ja, oder kann sich rechnen. Das wäre jetzt die Frage, wenn man jetzt Kredite
abschließen würde, dann hat man jetzt das mit hohen Zinsen zu tun.
Man schließt einen Kredit über zehn Jahre beispielsweise mit der Bindung ab.
Und was ist, wenn die Zinsen weiter steigen? Ja, dann hat man Glück gehabt.
Aber wenn die Zinsen auf zwei Prozent wieder fallen, dann sagt die Bank nicht,
ach so, da haben wir ja viel Geld an ihnen verdient, da bekommen sie ein bisschen
was zurück. Im Übrigen will ich hier noch mal sagen, dass es schändlich ist,
wie die Banken umgehen mit ihren Kunden.
Die geben die Zinsen nicht weiter, die sie da einnehmen.
Man bekommt mehr Zinsen bei Apple, wenn man da was abschließt.
Das stimmt.
Als bei den hier so geschätzten kleinen Banken. Das ist unglaublich, was hier stattfindet.
Das haben dann auch zwei Parteien erkannt, die man nicht so gleich zusammendeckt.
CDU und Linke fordern deshalb vom Bildungsministerium, die höheren Zinsen durch
staatliche Zuschüsse auszugleichen.
So wurde es auch während der Corona-Pandemie gehandhabt.
Das gab es auch schon mal.
So hat die KfW 2008 die Zinsen erhöht. Die Erhöhung nach einem Gespräch mit
dem Bildungsministerium aber wieder zurückgenommen.
Diese Möglichkeit gäbe es heute nicht mehr, sagt Brandenburg.
Es wurde uns sehr klar versichert, dass die KfW momentan kostendeckend arbeitet und kein...
Kostendeckend. Also das ist jetzt Jens Brandenburg.
Eine Märde plus ist kostendeckend.
Dreimal dürft ihr raten, welche Partei. Natürlich FDP.
Spielraum zur weiteren Senkung der Zinsen sieht. Die KfW selbst hat auf eine
Anfrage des Deutschlandfunks bisher nicht geantwortet.
Und das Bildungsministerium stellt klar, dass Absolventen nicht auf staatliche Hilfe hoffen können.
Mit einem verbesserten Zugang zum BAföG und einem neuen Bildungskredit der KfW
konzentriere man sich auf die künftigen Studenten.
Also die künftigen Studenten sind sowieso nur interessant. Die anderen müssen
halt jetzt sehen, wo sie bleiben. Pech gehabt.
Vor allem man interessiert sich für die künftigen Studenten.
Was ist denn das für ein Spruch? Also wir haben doch gegenwärtige Studenten.
Ja, wieso kann man die denn ausblenden?
Hört ihr das mal an.
Unsere Aufgabe als Staat ist ja vor allem sicherzustellen, dass der Zugang zum
Studium keine Frage der sozialen oder finanziellen Herkunft ist.
Und das ist der klare Fokus der Koalition.
Das sagt jetzt der Brandenburg von der KfW. Aber er sagt damit,
ja wir machen so einen Zugang, den ermöglichen wir.
Wie es aber den Leuten danach damit geht, ob die dann unter der Zinslast leiden
oder nicht, ist uns eigentlich egal. Wir wollen nur nachweisen können,
na seht ihr, wer will kann kommen.
Ja, es ist ja ein bisschen so, das Bildungssystem hat ja grundsätzlich die Aufgabe,
dir Handlungsvermögen zu verschaffen.
Also intellektuelle Grundlagen zu legen, auf denen man dann,
wenn sie allgemein und breit genug sind, breite Bildung, spezifisch aufbauen kann.
Man studiert also etwas, damit das Unternehmen sich weniger darauf fokussieren
muss, dir nochmal beizubringen, wie etwas geht, sondern einfach draufsatteln kann,
was vorher schon an Ermöglichungen, Eröffnungen von Möglichkeiten und so weiter geleistet wurde.
Ein Kredit aufzunehmen, und das ist ja gerade in Deutschland,
jetzt höre ich mich schon fast an wie Heinz Bude, wenn er über Stimmungen schreibt.
Ein Kredit wird ja in Deutschland ausschließlich unter, nein,
dann beschränken wir die Handlungsmöglichkeiten der zukünftigen Generation,
also unseren eigenen kollektiven Kopf sozusagen, wir müssen aber Handlungsmöglichkeiten schaffen.
Also Schuldenbremse, bloß kein Schuldenberg.
Schuldenberge sind das Allerschlimmste auf der Welt. So.
Und wir sagen ja immer, ne private Haushalte, öffentliche Haushalte funktionieren unterschiedlich.
Und alles was wir über Schuldenbremsen, öffentliche Investitionen und so weiter
über Kredite sagen, nämlich, dass das Zukunft verkleinert, dass uns das Handlungsmöglichkeiten
nimmt, das gilt ja für den Staat nicht, aber für den Privaten dann doch.
Also beim Bildungskredit stimmt doch alles, was ideologisch den Staatsschulden untergejubelt wird.
Und dass wir dann ein Bildung, also wir eröffnen uns Möglichkeiten und das aber
nur ermöglichen, umsetzen können über, ja wir nehmen dir aber dann auch ganz
viele Federzellemöglichkeiten.
Das ist doch bescheuert. Also das macht doch wirklich logisch gar keinen Sinn,
dass wir das so organisieren.
Kommen wir noch zu einem anderen Thema. Sprechen wir mal ganz kurz über Die Linke.
Also Die Linke jetzt ohne Wagenknecht und Co.
Und diese Linke hat ja auch eine...
Es wurde nur die Fraktion aufgelöst. Große Aufregung im Internet,
dass es die Linke-Geschichte ist oder so.
Ja, ja. Die gibt es noch. Und es war beispielsweise Carola Rakete bei Thilo im Interview.
Wir hören nur mal kurz in das Gespräch rein und versuchen uns mal an einer Stilkritik.
Wie stehst du zum Milliardären? Bernie Sanders hat hier vor kurzem gesessen
und meinte, die sollen gar nicht existieren.
Ja genau, und du weißt ja, man sollte die alle aufessen.
Wirklich? Naja. Natürlich nicht wirklich. Ich bin gegen Kannibalismus.
Ja, muss ich jetzt vielleicht auch noch dazu sagen. Carola Rackete offenbar nicht.
Sollte ich jetzt vielleicht auch noch dazu sagen. Natürlich war es ein Scherz.
Aber es ist natürlich schon spannend, ob man wirklich mal eine Vermögens-Obergrenze
einführen könnte. Das wäre jetzt mal eine Frage gewesen.
Also ich fände es gut. Also man könnte ja einfach sagen.
Das ist ja schließlich gegen unsere freiheitliche Grundlage.
Ja und dann geht das immer so weiter und man merkt jetzt schon,
dass es einem weh tut, auch wenn man sagen würde, ja eine Vermögens-Obergrenze,
kann man mal drüber nachdenken, aber ich begreife nicht, wie man so schlecht performen kann.
Man sagt ja irgendwas mit eat the rich, weil man mal gesehen hat,
das hat was mit dem Hashtag zu tun und der ist beliebt und das hat auch AOC gemacht,
aber man kann überhaupt nicht performen, sondern sitzt da in so einer Schluterigkeit
und redet auch so, dass man sagt, ja irgendwie, ja müssten wir das machen.
Also wen soll das ansprechen? Soll das irgendjemanden, der wenig verdient ansprechen
und sagen, oh das wäre aber toll, wenn die was nehmen?
Wird dem dadurch klar, dass er mehr bekommt? Nö, wird dem überhaupt nicht klar.
Ist das für, also ich will das nur auch mal nur strategisch machen.
Also welches Publikum könnte man erreichen?
Ja, man kann natürlich das Kaola-Rakete-Publikum, ihre Fans erreichen.
Aber das ist ja nicht das womit man erfolgreiche Politik machen kann.
Wenn man sich einmal in Deutschland umsieht und die drei, vier Großstädte verlässt,
dann weiß man ja in etwa wie Leute reden, denken und tun.
Und dann sitzt man da in dieser Art, dann will man doch einfach 80 Millionen
Menschen in Deutschland überhaupt nicht erreichen.
Ich finde es vor allem problematisch, dass ich jetzt einen meiner Lieblingssprüche,
eat the rich, wieder retten muss.
Denn hier ist man ja wirklich fast peinlich berührt, in dem Fall von einem Menschen.
Ich will jetzt schildern, wie es ist, wenn ich sage Siri.
Erzähl mir Witze, damit meine Kinder darüber lachen.
Und dann nimmt Siri aber, und ich höre das natürlich, äh, am inhaltlichen Verlauf
der Jokes, englische Witze, übersetzt sie auf Deutsch, und dann funktioniert die nicht. So.
Also, wie willst du mit Milliarden ... Ja, ich will sie aufessen.
Nee, diesen Spruch gibt's nur auf Englisch. Also, das ist, äh, nun mal, wie's ist.
Und ich finde, nicht nur gibt's den nicht, also nur auf Englisch,
sondern man darf ihn auch nicht aussprechen. Der ist dafür da,
um so hingeschrieben zu werden, um in ein 300 Euro teures Hemd hinten eingestickt
zu werden, mit anderer Farbe oder wie auch immer, so auf der Ebene.
Aber nicht auf Deutsch übersetzen und aussprechen. Also das ist einfach...
Es ist keine Politik. Es ist Nonsens. Dann glaubt man, man kann mit drei Slogans doch irgendwas machen.
Und deswegen dachte ich, wir wagen uns heute mal noch ein bisschen weiter in die Stilkritik.
Und ich stehe ja nicht im Verdacht, dass ich der der Linken grundsätzlich feindlich
gesinnt bin, sondern dass ich ja durchaus damit vielen Punkten sympathisieren kann.
Aber ich muss sagen, wie dort aufgetreten wird, ist grundfalsch.
Und ich rede jetzt nur strategisch, weil jetzt manche sagen werden,
ja, du sitzt da in deinem Zweireiher mit der Krawatte und wirst jetzt da irgendwie persönlich.
Nein, ich stelle mir nur, ich stelle mir bei Politik schon lange nicht mehr
die Frage, ob mich das anspricht.
Also da sind wir eh völlig raus.
Also diese Frage darf ich mir gar nicht stellen.
Also das ist bei mir, was mich sprechen noch irgendwie die Bilder von Brigitte
und Emmanuel Macron an modisch.
Aber sonst muss ich das völlig ausklammern. Das ist hier nicht die Frage.
Ich frage mich, die Leute so im Land, überall verteilt, werden die angesprochen oder nicht?
Die Frage haben wir uns jetzt gestellt und wir sehen uns jetzt ein Foto an und
es ist gut, dass es ein Podcast ist, weil man dieses Foto jetzt nicht sehen kann.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich da hinkomme auf dieses Foto jetzt da unten.
Achso, wir müssten jetzt Carola Rakete, wir erklären kurz wie der Podcast funktioniert,
bis zu Ende hören. Ich sehe da unten, es läuft noch zwei Minuten, zwei.
Das wollen wir beide nicht.
Dann würde mit deinem Klicker automatisch
das Foto erscheinen oder ich überspringe einfach Carola Rakete.
Mach das doch mal. Also wir sehen jetzt hier ein Foto, das ist bei dem letzten
linken Parteitag geschossen worden und wir sagen auch nicht,
wer jetzt darauf zu sehen ist. Das geht mir jetzt nicht darum, einzelne vorzuführen.
Wir sehen jetzt vier linke Spitzenpolitiker, zwei Männer, zwei Frauen.
Der eine Mann trägt eine schwarze Jeans, ein schwarzes T-Shirt und ein graues
Sakko und da würde ich sagen, das geht noch gerade so, es ist halt maximal unauffällig.
Ich gehe weiter, daneben steht eine Dame, die trägt eine derart weite Hose,
wie sie glaube ich treuste waren, nicht mal anziehen würde und irgendwelche
grauen Sportturnschuhe.
Darüber trägt sie ein viel zu weites, lappriges, merkwürdig blau, ozeanblaues T-Shirt.
Daneben steht eine Dame, die eine merkwürdige Turnschuhkonstruktion trägt mit
Leggings drüber, einem Rock, aber auch noch Stulpen hochgezogen,
plus über dem Kleid dann noch eine Jeansjacke, die eine Nummer oder zwei zu klein ist.
Und daneben steht ein Herr mit viel zu langen Jeanshosen.
Einem Turnschuhfabrikat, das auch die besten Zeiten hinter sich hat und einem völlig ungebügelten,
grau-schwarzen Hemd, wobei ich nicht sicher bin, ob das Hemd vielleicht mal
schwarz war und durchs viele Waschen grau geworden ist.
Also mit anderen Worten, es sieht grauenhaft aus.
Und nochmal, mir geht es jetzt hier nicht darum zu sagen, geht mal alle euch
schöne Anzüge und Blazer und so weiter kaufen.
Aber man muss sich glaube ich schon, wenn man Spitzenpersonal sein will,
denn man hat ja eine Aufgabe, repräsentieren.
Alles andere wird ja im Hintergrund gemacht. Wenn man das machen will,
repräsentieren, dann muss man sich schon mal die Frage stellen,
wie komme ich seriös rüber, wenn ich auch noch hinzufüge, ah ja,
die Linke gilt bei ja vielen immer noch so als unseriös oder sind das am Ende Kommunisten.
Also das sind ja die permanenten Unterstellungen, die so mitgeführt werden und
dann muss man versuchen, möglichst seriös aufzutreten. Es geht darum.
Eine Ernsthaftigkeit an den Tag zu gehen, die sich dann auch vestimentär ausdrückt.
Und es geht jetzt nicht darum, eine Modenschau zu machen. Ja,
ich würde jetzt niemandem sagen, ich will Designerkleidung oder sonst irgendetwas
sehen. Das ist völliger Unsinn.
Aber man kann auch mit ganz wenig Geld im Übrigen sich vernünftig anziehen.
Und ich habe das ja hier auch schon im Podcast oft gesagt, wenn man eine dunkle
Hose und ein weißes Hemd als Mann anzieht, dann hat man schon mal relativ viel richtig gemacht.
Wenn man dieses Hemd dann zwei Knöpfe auflässt, ich habe es alles schon mal
erklärt, sich mal darüber Gedanken macht, wie muss eigentlich ein Hemd sitzen,
dann ist schon viel gewonnen.
Und bei den Frauen gibt es ja ganz viele Alternativen. Und als ich das so sah,
habe ich über etwas nachgedacht.
Ich will dich jetzt mal mit einem Gedankenexperiment konfrontieren.
Wir haben ja schon häufiger darüber geredet, wie ist das eigentlich mit beispielsweise
amerikanischen Präsidenten?
Ist der der Präsident oder spielt der den Präsidenten? Das sind ja die Fragen,
die uns dann besonders anflogen zu Zeiten von Trump.
Und jetzt mal meine Idee, wenn ich hier so sehe, Repräsentation funktioniert bei den Linken nicht.
Gehen wir jetzt mal davon aus, die Inhalte wären alle gut, dann kann man doch
mal überlegen, Wenn wir sagen, dass ein Präsident einer ist,
der performativ den Akt vollzieht, indem er so redet wie ein Präsident,
so aussieht, so auftritt.
Warum nimmt man eigentlich nicht gleich einen Schauspieler? Und ich meine jetzt
nicht im Sinne von Trump oder Zelensky, also Leute, die Medienstars waren und
dann sagen, ich möchte jetzt aber Politik machen.
Sondern man könnte ja doch jetzt als beispielsweise die Linke sagen,
Wir gucken mal im Schauspiel Frankfurt oder sonst wo, wer gefällt uns da gut,
wer könnte da jetzt den Vorsitzenden spielen.
Dem ziehen wir entsprechend was an, da sagen wir auch hier so ein bisschen mehr
den intellektuellen Ductus an den Tag legen.
Dann brauchen wir noch eine zweite Person, die vielleicht so ein bisschen Ruhrpott-Charme
mit reinbringt, vielleicht noch ein bisschen Dialekt.
Und dann kann man doch sagen, Schauspieler bekommen im Festvertrag irgendwie
so dreieinhalbtausend oder was an einem mittelgroßen Theater,
das kann man ja auch zahlen.
Und dann macht man das ja mal ganz transparent, also nicht, dass es nachher
auffängt, sondern sagt, wir haben uns geglaubt, wir konzentrieren uns auf die
Inhalte, aber Performance liegt uns nicht so, wie Sie an den Fotos hier sehen.
Wir schicken aber die Leute in die Talkshows, die bereiten sich gut vor, die lernen die Texte,
die wissen, wenn sie gefragt werden, was sollen wir mit Milliardären machen,
dann können die direkt ein paar Punkte aufzählen, dann können die charismatisch
sein, dann können die sich nochmal dran erinnern, wie hab ich eigentlich damals
in Richard der Dritte gespielt,
dann versuche ich das auch nochmal mit auf die Bühne bei Maischberger oder sonst
wo zu bringen. Wäre das eine Alternative?
Das wäre eine, denn wir wissen, sie funktioniert.
Karsten Lindemann ist so in Schauspieler.
Diese Leute rutschen ja nicht nur in die Politik rein, sondern wenn sie sich
für die CDU entscheiden, auch in einen Ausbildungsbetrieb, der ganz hart selegiert,
wer äußert sich denn hier im Ortsverband wie und vor allem wie häufig.
Also wer denn wirklich Lust auf die Orkstertour.
Dann gibt es diese Angebote, bewerb dich hier, dann kriegst du so die ersten
Vorstands und so weiter.
Damit rutscht du so in diesen Delegiertenapparat rein, bis du dann irgendwann
beim Bundesparteitag landest und dein Ortsverband oder vielleicht mal ein ganzes
Bundesland repräsentierst.
Wenn du da angekommen bist, und mit da meine ich dort, wo dann auch Fernsehkameras
stehen, bist du vorher schon handverlesen.
Es ist die Schauspielerauswahl nach diesen harten Kriterien,
wie du sie jetzt beschrieben hast, Text muss sitzen und Klamotte auch.
Nur, dass man halt einen sehr engen Pool hat, nämlich die eigene Parteijugend.
Also man kommt dann nicht aus dem Theater da rein rekrutiert,
sondern aus der eigenen Partei-Jugend, da dort aber auch über Jahrzehnte Theater
gespielt wurde, junger Union-Chef kann man sein, bis man 35 ist,
also wer aus der jungen Union nach oben befördert wird in die nächste Partei-Etage,
der hat schon 20 Jahre Parteipolitik auf dem Buckel.
Also es ist quasi nicht nur Schauspielschule, sondern dann auch Bühnenerfahrung für ein ganzes Leben.
Man spielt ja dann nicht nur abends, sondern den ganzen Tag.
Also man ist ja dann wirklich gestellt, was das angeht.
Und es ist doch immer die Empfehlung gewesen zu sagen, macht es ein bisschen wie die CDU.
Geht auf eine Demonstration so, dass niemand auf die Idee kommt,
ich kloppe den jetzt mal nieder, weil er hat ja nur eine Jeanshose an.
Sondern nein, man möchte gerne diesen straighten Gang nach vorne in seinem feinen Zwirn fortführen.
Und wer diesen Gang unterbrechen möchte, muss das schon rechtfertigen.
Kann nicht einfach mit einem Schlagknüppel kommen und sagen,
ich hau dir jetzt einen rüber.
Sondern man muss so aussehen, als repräsentierte man etwas.
Es ist ganz interessant, ich kam ja aus Rom, ich war ja die Woche in Rom,
um mir jetzt, nachdem ich es Jahrzehnte verpasst habe, mir mein geschichtliches
Interesse mal so ein bisschen empirisch zu unterfüttern.
Damals gab es Prozessionen durch die Stadt, da waren die Personen,
um die es geht, gar nicht anwesend, sondern die Sklaven liefen und haben einfach
die Büste, die im Hauseingang steht, vor sich hergetragen.
Und das hieß, Herr so und so ist da.
Allein seine Büste reicht dafür. Also man macht es über die Show,
da fällt dann nicht mal ein gesprochenes Wort oder so, sondern der Aufzug reicht.
Man ist auf der Straße zu sehen und sei es nur aus Stein gehauen.
Und da beginnt politische Repräsentation.
Und wir sind nun mal hier in einem Repräsentationssystem. Diese Leute stehen
auf der Bühne und wurden gekürt.
Und sie sehen dort so einen Fototermin, denn sonst brauchen wir keine Fotos machen.
Also weil jetzt manche denken werden, oh der Wolfgang ist aber oberflächlich. Überhaupt nicht.
Ich habe in meinem Bekanntenkreis lauter Leute, die nie Anzüge tragen und ich
habe kein Problem damit.
Alle wissen, dass ich Slavoj Žižek schätze.
Wie der rumläuft, brauchen wir nicht zu kommentieren. Das spielt alles keine Rolle.
Nur es fängt eine Rolle zu spielen, wenn ich sage, ich begebe mich dorthin.
Ich kann auch nicht auf eine Bühne gehen und sagen, ich bin Sänger.
Und kann aber keinen Ton rausbringen. Dann bin ich kein Sänger.
Das muss hier geleistet werden.
Ich beschreibe, was wir hier sehen. Vier Menschen, du hast es ja beschrieben.
Du hast jetzt sozusagen ihr Aussehen beschrieben. Ich beschreibe jetzt mal ihre Funktion.
Sie sind gekürt, um so wie sie da stehen einen Schritt nach vorne zu gehen.
Und dieser Schritt hieße, in einem Parlament nicht nur ihre eigene Partei zu
repräsentieren, sondern die Gesamtmenge eines Wahlvolks.
Ja.
Kennt man ja von den ganzen, Herr Klingbeil, wieso haben Sie Ihren Kanzler nicht
unter Kontrolle? Na, weil es nicht der Kanzler der SPD ist, sondern der Kanzler aller Deutschen.
Wir können jetzt nicht einfach nur die SPD-Linie beim Kanzler durchfuchteln,
denn der hat da nur 24 Prozent, der führt eine Koalition, der regiert ein Land.
Diese vier, die wir da sehen, stehen genau vor diesem Schritt,
nicht in Regierungspositionen, aber dann in legislativer, also in der gesetzgebenden
Gewalt im Rahmen eines Parlamentes, nicht nur für sich selber und ihre Partei,
sondern für alle zu sprechen.
So, und jetzt haben wir gegen jede linke Wunschvorstellung historische Erfahrung
damit, dass das Publikum repräsentiert werden möchte.
Insbesondere jüngst durch Nigel Farage, der den Brexit angeleiert hat und die
armen Häuser Englands für sich gewann in 5000 Euro teuren Anzügen.
Donald Trump, der im goldenen Prunk seines Trump Towers und so weiter die ärmsten
der Armen hinter sich geschart hat.
So, jetzt kann man das natürlich alles blöd finden, finden wir auch,
aber es funktioniert halt trotzdem so.
Wir reden hier strategisch.
Genau, wenn der Zugang zur Masse, die man braucht, ist, dass man ihr etwas vormacht,
was man vielleicht selbst nicht ist, muss man trotzdem Anzug anziehen.
Auch wenn man sich darin unwohl fühlt, man muss dann Anzug anziehen,
weil der Anzug ist die Uniform der Politik. Wir erwarten auch von der Flugbegleiterin,
dass sie so aussieht, dass wir glauben, ah, die hatte heute Morgen so viel Zeit,
sich fertig zu machen, anscheinend ist mit dem Flugzeug alles okay.
Anscheinend muss sie sich nicht noch darum kümmern und ist nicht abgehetzt mit,
oh, ich musste noch so viel unten das Öl wechseln und so weiter.
Ich konnte mich leider nicht umziehen.
Wollen Sie einen Orangensaft? Ne, da würden wir uns unsicher fühlen.
Und so wie wir es da verlangen, dass die Menschen uns zeigen,
dass alles in Ordnung ist, wollen wir das auch hier sehen. Wir wollen sehen,
dass alles in Ordnung ist.
Und solange Männer und Frauen in der Politik keine Anzüge oder entsprechende
Kostüme tragen, zeigen sie uns nicht, dass alles in Ordnung ist,
sondern dass sie immer noch... Wir unterstellen der FDP immer partikulare Interessen.
Wenn es hier einfach heißt, nee, ich kümmere mich selber um mich und so weiter,
dann prügelt man ein partikularistisches Interesse durch.
Und genügt nicht den Anforderungen der Allgemeinheit und die läuft nun mal in
der Politik ganz sichtbar über die Kleiderordnung.
Man hat nicht sehr viele Möglichkeiten, man hat kein Zepter mehr,
man hat keine Büste mehr, man kann nicht mehr mit dem Reisapfel rumfuchteln
und sagen, ich bin's, sondern man muss jetzt zeigen, dass man es ernst meint
und das geht nicht in dieser Klamotte. In der Hinsicht können wir ja jetzt für
uns so einen Appell anschließen an die Politik.
Wir möchten unsere Bühnenuniformen gerne von der Steuer absetzen.
Es ist ein echtes Problem, dass das alles privat bezahlt werden muss.
Gut, du weißt, das würde mich retten. Und zwar, also das wäre tatsächlich,
wenn ich meine Anzüge absetzen könnte.
Da blieb kein Steuerlast mehr übrig bei Wolfgang, wenn er jetzt seine Anzüge absetzen könnte.
Ja, also das könnte man ja so über diesen Weg dann ermöglichen.
Vielleicht. Also die Partei wähle ich dann, die das ermöglicht.
Und falls jetzt wieder und so weiter, schreibt gerne Kommentare.
Wir wollen, dass die Linksgesinnten, die uns hier zuhören, jetzt auch wütend
sind darüber, was wir sagen. Aber wir haben halt die Wahrheit gesagt.
Ja, und teilt es ruhig mal in den sozialen Medien und so. Das hilft unserem
Podcast und hilft vielleicht aber auch mal der Debatte.
Und wir haben ja schon, Stefan hat sich ja schon hier in Position gebracht als
Populismusbeauftragter für die Grünen. Und vielleicht braucht es auch noch einen
Modeberater und da will ich hier auch noch mal nochmal.
Wolfgang möchte gar nicht Zeugwart der Linken werden.
Ne, ich möchte, ich möchte nochmal. Sehr schönes Wort, ja.
Ich möchte hier nochmal deutlich unterstreichen, das ist nicht nur ein linkes Problem.
Also hier ist es ganz besonders aufgetaucht, aber ich sehe Schlimmes auch auf grünen Parteitagen.
Mitunter auch bei der bei der jungen Union. Also wir wollen jetzt hier nicht
so tun, auch die die SPD hat Aussetzer zum Teil bei Spitzenpersonal, da kriegt man die Krise.
Und ich meine jetzt nicht den Bundeskanzler oder so, sondern andere,
die aber sehr exponiert sind.
Das heißt, es gibt generell großen Nachholbedarf, wie und das ist das,
was ich mir vorstelle, dass wir in der Zukunft,
Bindet man eigentlich eine Krawatte und wann lässt man sie aus und wie sieht
es aus, wenn man sie auslässt? Ist es wirklich sinnvoll?
Und das führt uns aber dann in den Salon, da werden wir genau das nochmal aufgreifen.
Wird die Krawatte aussterben? Eine interessante Kolumne aus der New York Times
habe ich da mitgebracht.
Das sind die wichtigen Themen.
Ich finde schon, daran zeigt sich ganz ganz viel.
Wir können ja nochmal ein was sagen. Ja. Grundsätzlich gilt,
wer die CDU vom Thron schubsen will, muss besser angezogen sein als die CDU.
Ja.
Was bedeutet, wir alle überprüfen gegen Jahresende, den neuen genauen Sendetermin
kennen wir ja noch nicht, ob euer Lieblings-Podcaster, ich, im Fernsehen besser
angezogen ist als Johannes Winkel von der Jungen Union.
Okay, das schauen wir uns an. Also wir sprechen im Salon über die Krawatte.
Ich habe einen grandiosen Roman dabei, Sauhund heißt der von Leon Christ,
den ich vorstellen will.
Dann geht es darum, was denken eigentlich die rechten Intellektuellen,
also die auch Teil der republikanischen Partei sind, über den Krieg in der Ukraine.
Ich habe einen sehr, sehr langen Aufsatz gelesen aus einer konservativen Zeitschrift.
Das wird sehr sehr spannend.
Außerdem, wie wird gestreikt und was machen die Betriebsräte so und die Gewerkschaften?
Es gibt einen interessanten Fall hier in Frankfurt.
Da wurde nämlich eine Brauerei geschlossen. Darüber werden wir reden und wie
auch schon angekündigt wird es darum gehen, dass die Vorstellung,
dass wir bald alle autonom fahren.
Ja, ein schöner Traum ist, aber er wird nicht kommen.
Ich finde, das ist ein sehr, sehr guter Text. Ich habe mich auch natürlich,
hätte mich gefreut, wenn es anders käme, aber ja, so wird es wohl sein.
Das sind die Themen. Was hast du dabei?
Wir lesen, weil es ja so rein faktisch jetzt der letzte Lesesalon dieses Jahres ist,
Texte, von denen ich sage, dass es so wohltuend ist, das ist wie so eine gute
Rückenmassage, aber einfach für den Kopf.
Wir lesen zwei Texte, die einfach komplett unsere Meinung widerspiegeln.
Sehr gut.
Aber eben nicht nur von uns, sondern einfach mal so von Juristen und Ökonomen vorgetragen.
Das ist zum einen Lukas Mertin, der hat im Verfassungsblock einen Text über
den Katalysator der Polikrise geschrieben.
Also das Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts mit so herausragend wohltuenden
Formulierungen, dass es wirklich eine Freude ist, das zu lesen,
weshalb wir da immer so richtig lesen. Außerdem Migration und Fachkräftemangel von Marcel Fratscher.
Der schreibt ja alle zwei Wochen in der Zeit oder bei Zeit Online.
Diesen Text gehen wir auch mal durch. Außerdem die New York Times über die Sprache Donald Trumps.
Ich als großer Fan und auch Werber dafür, Sozialstruktur und Semantik klar zu unterscheiden.
Und nicht immer die Semantik als nur, es ist Glaber und so. sondern nein,
die Verknüpfung von Semantik und Struktur ist wichtig.
Also ist auch wichtig, wie politisch gesprochen wird.
Und da Donald Trump der nächste amerikanische Präsident ist,
sollten wir uns das nochmal genau anschauen.
Und zum Abschluss, YouTube macht sich jetzt offen für Deepfakes.
Also wir hatten ganz lange so ein paar Restriktionen, keine Pornografie,
kennen wir ja, Fake News, Irgendwelche Labels zum Thema, hier wird über Corona
gesprochen, seid vorsichtig, wie auch immer.
Beim Thema Künstliche Intelligenz stellt jetzt Inhalte her, ist YouTube alles egal?
Und da macht Casey Newton eine ganz interessante Beobachtung,
die uns, glaube ich, noch auf Jahrzehnte vor große Probleme stellt.
Ähm, ja, wir kennen das ja aus verschiedenen Herangehensweisen,
dass manchmal, ja, diese Long-Term-Wissen-Idee ...
Irgendwelche großen Entwicklungslinien gerade beginnen und noch so formbar sind
und da sind wir gerade an so einem ganz merkwürdigen Punkt, was uns direkt dann
in Taylor Lawrence Buch führt, die ja auch.
Das ist ja das Buch, über das wir ganz ausführlich reden werden.
Ich bin schon sehr gespannt, was du alles dazu zu sagen hast.
Extremly Online, the Untold Story of Fame, Influence and Power on the Internet von Taylor Lawrence.
Das ist ein Buch, das man liest und man denkt sich, wie kann das eigentlich sein?
Ich habe doch die letzten 20 Jahre mitbekommen und könnte ja auch politisch
so sagen, was gelaufen ist.
Und hier habe ich sogar die ganze Zeit teilgenommen mit meinem Tablet oder Smartphone
und trotzdem bekomme ich hier eine Geschichte des Internets,
der sozialen Medien erzählt, die mich immer wieder überrascht und die glaube
ich tatsächlich eine ideale Grundlage ist für Diskussionen im Salon.
So ist es. Also hören wir uns gleich.
Du sagst aber noch, wie wir in den Salon kommen.
Ah ja. Also man fährt auf die Autobahn, dann zweimal links.
Wir müssen erstmal sagen, dass wir leider noch nicht ankündigen können,
wie jetzt die Karten bestellt werden können für das Sommer-Event.
Das verzögert sich noch ein bisschen, aber es findet definitiv im August statt.
Und wir müssen das nochmal ein klein bisschen vertagen.
Organisatorisch muss natürlich alles rund sein, bevor wir euch da E-Mails schreiben lassen.
Ja, nicht, dass nachher alles schief geht, aber sag noch, wie wir in den Salon kommen.
Wir gehen auf neue20er.de, lassen uns blenden von diesem goldenen Button,
auf dem der Salon steht und dort ist man dann bei Steady.
Wir bevorzugen ja bei Steady einfach sich eins der drei Pakete auszusuchen,
ab 2,50 Euro ist man also im Salon, hat Zugang zum ganzen Archiv seit Februar 2020.
Es sind 50, 60, 70, inzwischen bestimmt 80 Bücher, die wir besprochen haben.
Alternativ geht man bei Apple, wenn man eh schon über die Podcast-App hört,
kann man einfach im regulären Feed der 29er auf, ah ja, da ist ja eine Folge,
wo steht ich muss bezahlen, also bezahle ich, kostet aber 3,50 Euro.
Oder, falls man schon einen Account hat, geht man zu Patreon,
aber wir bevorzugen da Steady.
Bis gleich.